hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the very last
chapter of his treatise on freedom of
choice and some is going to make a
five-fold distinction between different
types or fundamental sorts of this
freedom of choice and the first
distinction that he's going to draw
separates out God from all other
creatures and he's not actually going to
say that much about the divine freedom
at this point other than to tell us that
one type of freedom of choice is
unoriginal ating that I say meaning it
comes from itself and it's not created
it's you know not [ __ ] up it's not
received from another I'll equal a kept
up and as Anselm tells us that type of
freedom only pertains to one being or if
you like you know the it's not three
beings in the Trinity but there's
there's a try you know try unity there
right as we talked about in the mona
logan and so this is the only thing that
that sort of uncreated freedom applies
to
and that's all he really has to say
about that topic at that point then he
goes into some other distinctions that
have to do with created and notice not
all created beings only created rational
beings and so that only includes two
types of beings human beings and the
good and bad angels so he talks about
freedom of choice that is in fact
created and received it's created by God
it's received from God by the creatures
that have it and so the first
fundamental distinction breaking this
down that Anselm makes is between
freedom of choice that does have
uprightness rectitude oh also
translators rectitude rightness a lot of
different ways
justice is another way in which an Psalm
talks about this in a very expansive
sense of the term justice so freedom of
choice that does have uprightness and
freedom of choice that does not have or
that lacks uprightness and uprightness
of what uprightness of will and some
defines justice as uprightness of will
maintained for its own sake so some
beings that have freedom of choice it's
combined with this or it can be said to
have this because freedom of choice is
in fact the ability to keep that very
rightness that very rectitude oh so
let's look at the first division that he
talks about he breaks that down into two
other two other groups as well so
freedom of choice that does have
uprightness and he talks about so as to
be able to lose it or in in the latin
separability where the rectitude or
rightness could be separated from that
that freedom of choice or in other words
the ability to keep rightness of will
for its own sake could be lacking that
rightness of will it doesn't actually
lack it but it could lack it
why would it lack it well because
somebody would give it up somebody would
abandon it to use Anselm's terminology
so who does this apply to well good
humans in this life people who actually
do have rectitude of will and therefore
ought to keep it but might not maybe
they go along as you know some of the
monks that Kassian talks about in his
conferences and Institute's who are
doing great until their final days and
then you know they abandon rectitude and
go off and do whatever they're gonna do
that's a possibility for them right it's
also a possibility a possibility that no
longer exists for the possibility that
did exist according to an stone for the
angels before they committed themselves
one way or another there's there's a
nice framing for this all the angels
before the good ones were confirmed in
the evil ones fell all right so that's
one division of this and then freedom of
choice that does have uprightness in
such a way so as not to be able to lose
it in separability where it's now become
you know part of that and has been
confirmed here he talks about the elect
and he uses the you know the term elect
to us right elect angels and humans the
chosen the and and really not just God
that God has chosen them but they chose
to be the way that they were supposed to
be to hold on to that rectitude that
rightness so they are confirmed in that
that would be the angels that are good
now because they can't you know change
in that respect and humans who have died
and died with that rectitude and now
have it for all of eternity so good for
for those two groups right one can lose
it one cannot lose it then we have
freedom of choice that does not have
uprightness of will where it could if
that uprightness were given back to it
it could accept that uprightness of will
and maintain it for its own sake but in
point of fact it does not have it
and here he talks again makes a
important distinction between those who
are able to recover it and those who are
unable to recover it so those who are
able to recover it he uses the Latin
term for a Cooper or a Billy Tanner in
such a way as to be able to recuperate
it and write where they can receive it
back that would be bad people people
that are lacking justice in their will
rightness of will at this point in time
he says characterizes only human beings
who lack it during their lifetime and he
says many may not recover it and then in
that case they would fall into the the
second class he says the freedom of
choice which does not have uprightness
of will and is not able to recover it is
characteristic of reprobate and that's
just you know actually the Latin term
that's being used they're condemned
angels and human beings reprobate angels
after the fall so now and human beings
after their lifetime and the the word
that it uses they're talking about
inability to recover it ear recupera
billy tear in such a ways that cannot be
recovered so they have sort of you know
stuck themselves it ontologically into a
condition that they can no longer escape
and they will not be given that
uprightness back and so it's kind of a
moot point whether they could in fact
accept it because in point of fact they
will not be given it back according to
anthem so we have five different classes
of this freedom of choice discussed at
the end of this text as i pointed out
one pertains just to god doesn't really
you know enter into our discussions here
because the Anselm doesn't clarify that
any further but he has this nice
analytic distinction into all these
other classes those who who you know
have uprightness those who don't have
uprightness and then two classes or
subclasses
in each of those making a total of five
and no you might say well why did Anselm
go through this class offical
exercise it was to try to show that he
actually has covered all of the
different bases all the different
modalities that this freedom of choice
Libertas are bid three could in fact
take on and so that's why he's ending
his considerations here with this
classification of five different types
five distinct types of freedom of choice
in relation to its origins and in
relation to whether it has rectitude or
rightness of will and the modality in
which it has or doesn't have it
you